ÇMein Fazit zu diesem Buch ist:
Es ist ein mittelmŠssiges Buch,
aber wenigstens ist es dŸnn.È
ÇDon DeLillo ÜDie StilleÝ.
DeLillo, DeLillo, DeLillo.È
ÇDeLillo, DeLillo, DeLillo.È
ÇDieser Roman erzŠhlt davon,
wie von einem Moment
auf den anderen alles
wegbricht, die ganze
digitale Gesellschaft sozusagen
einem Blackout verfŠllt.
Und jetzt mŸssen
die Menschen damit umgehen.È
ÇBlackout. Leute reden.
Das Licht bleibt aus.
Damit wŠre schon alles gesagt,
wenn du mich fragst.È
ÇWas er hier zeigen will,
ist ja auch, sozusagen
wie mit einem Komplett-
Blackout alles wegbricht
und man sowieso gar nicht mehr
an der Welt teilhaben kann.È
ÇNicola, ich weiss nicht,
ob es wirklich
eine zulŠssige Technik ist,
ein Buch, was ein Blackout
behandelt mit den
literarischen Blackouts...È
ÇJa natŸrlich. Das ist
doch Sinn der Sache.
Thema ist der Blackout.
Und wie macht er es?
Er setzt es formal genau so um
wie das, was er zeigt.
Das ist eine sehr stimmige...È
Ç...mit seinen Mitteln versagt
und selbst ein Blackout
beim Schreiben erleidet.È
ÇNein, geschrieben ist es super.È
ÇEs ist nicht super
geschrieben, my dear.È
ÇEs zeigt einfach,
dass die Menschen
nicht mehr miteinander
sprechen kšnnen,
dass sie auf sich selbst...È
ÇJa aber das hat ja nichts mit
einem Blackout zu tun.È
ÇDer eine... Es gibt
ja zwei Szenarien.
Der Flugzeugabsturz,
und dann gibt es in New York
in einem Apartment
drei Menschen,
die den Superbowl
schauen wollen.
Auch da wird der
Bildschirm schwarz.
Und dann fŠngt der Mann
an zu erzŠhlen,
was er alles nicht sieht.
Das ist doch grossartig.È
ÇNein, das ist eine kŸnstliche
und ein bisschen
nervtštende Patchwork-Technik,
wo Leute einfach
reduziert werden
auf den Transport
von Botschaften.
Dieser auch noch anwesende
Student zum Beispiel,
der dauernd
theoretische VersatzstŸcke
von Bitcoin bis Einstein,
damit alle popkulturellen
Stichworte mal hier
auf diesem schmalen Platz
erwŠhnt worden sind.
Das ist eine dermassen
auch einfache Technik.
Dieses Buch kann man wirklich
in drei Stunden schreiben.
Das ist wie eine Skizze
zu einem besseren Buch.
Willst du doch Ÿber den
Corona-Trick sprechen?È
ÇCorona rein, Corona raus.È
ÇKurz vor Drucklegung
hat er diesen einen Satz
zu Corona reingetan.È
ÇUnd jetzt kommt er wieder raus.È
ÇUnd jetzt kommt er
wieder raus,
weil er gemerkt hat,
dass das alles
viel zu stark
auf Corona gelesen wird.È
ÇDieses Buch behandelt
den Konflikt zwischen
Technik, kŸnstlicher Intelligenz
und menschlichem Bewusstsein.
Und das war ein Konflikt,
der sehr wichtig war vor Corona.
Jetzt mit Corona beschŠftigen
wir uns plštzlich
mit dem Konflikt zwischen
menschlicher Biologie
und †berleben.
Dann ist das Problem
aufgetaucht,
dass dieses Buch plštzlich
aus der Zeit fŠllt.
Und so wurde das dann
versucht hinzubiegen.
Das ist meine Theorie.È
ÇEs ist ein gutes Buch,
es gibt bessere
von Don DeLillo
und trotzdem ist es immer
noch besser als vieles andere,
was ich in letzter Zeit gelesen habe.È